[Music]
what's the worst date you guys ever been
on in your whole life yeah the worst
dates did you only see 911
oh i see worst date yeah that would be a
bad day yeah that's gonna be a bad day i
don't know if i had any really bad ones
i forget all my dates are [ __ ]
there's a snapshot
lit
i repress those in my memory
go first i can't remember remember joe
yeah me neither i went on a blind double
date once and then
i was so like i did not like the girl at
all so bad that i i made an excuse up
and i left in the middle of it like we
didn't even we sat down that sounds
terrible we didn't order anything so
your lady just stayed there
yeah and i was like yo i gotta go bro
what's wrong with the chicks called her
bro uh i did call her bro um
i sh i just we just as soon as she
started talking to me i was like oh this
this can't happen like i am gay
i was like you don't get a dick your
boy's out and i left wait you're a woman
that's when you realize that you are gay
actual crazy
wow you look like a real man in your
profile yeah
the jawline and everything it was crazy
what you got rick you got anything i was
expecting a man what the [ __ ] we're
going to skip anthony because he
probably just had sex all the time
so uh there was a tick tock influencer
who went viral um for a video where she
describes her worst date ever she says
that she met her date on a dating app
and then he um
had her pick him up
from his house
uh so that they could go get food
together this from the chick's
perspective yeah it's all from the
chicks perspective
she says that he uh he gets in the car
and then he's like let's go to taco bell
damn
that's not what i said where he
where he proceeded to order 100 tacos no
way
from the drive-through
that 401 100 taco i was the girl driving
i'm leaving the driver yeah i'm like no
we're not i would have been like i can't
eat that much bro like like let me just
see though i want to see how this goes
is that [ __ ] yours is he subliminally
trying to be like talking about her taco
i mean he did it a hundred times so
maybe it's not that simple 100 tacos not
date's over
that's it dude wait
and then what
so then
he he's like ah [ __ ] i forgot my [ __ ]
wallet
oh wait i just don't know where my oh i
left it probably back at the house there
so she had to pay for 100 tacos that he
ordered how much is that is that a
hundred dollars it's way more than a
hundred dollars i have no idea how much
it is probably like
yeah it's like a good deal it was dorito
locos too it wasn't even probably like a
dollar taco nowadays so then uh he's
like i got an idea he's like why don't
we take these back to my place
right and we'll you know we'll have the
tacos we'll have a little
dining experience
so um they get back to his house and
there's hella dudes there she goes
inside and his dad's sitting on the
and couch proceed to put the um all the
tacos out on the table
and then her date
yells
let's feast
and then they all just started eating
tacos
in complete silence what the [ __ ] her
day
her and the dad are just [ __ ] going
why is this girl like that enabling this
i watched the video right there's a
video it's a tick tock yeah
dad
doesn't say anything to the girl at
first right
he puts the tacos on the table he does
the let's feast then dad walks in
and quietly grabs a taco and starts
eating it he wasn't invited to the table
but he's like it's a hundred [ __ ]
tacos here
what is this chick doing and then ask
the girl
if she wants to see his studio
dad
like like a music studio nobody knows at
that point she was like all right i'm
[ __ ] out here oh at that point she's
out
[ __ ] what's her breaking point right
maybe the date was coming afterwards
maybe he was maybe he was just hungry
you know he's like let's go to the
bathroom together she's like i don't
know about this
all right one more okay
i'm already here i don't know where my
line is
dude this chick is crazy she should have
left already no she she says that
repeatedly doing a video she knew but at
that point she was like
i don't know man that's kind of
intriguing right it's like if you're
that studio is a dexter kill room
it has to be that's correct dude if this
is my daughter i'm yelling at my
daughter
i'm grabbing her by her her shirt and
i'm shaking her dad who's about his dad
was probably like i'm [ __ ] hungry go
get one of your girls to [ __ ] get me
some tacos i do think yelling let's
feast is something i will be
incorporating into oh yeah that's
exactly what i
is this guy like handsome as [ __ ]
that's the coolest thing he did she
doesn't say
he's probably gotta be dude i don't know
i don't maybe i'm old-fashioned but i
feel like if i was a chick the minute a
dude goes can you pick me up yeah right
now
next he finessed everything everything
like he didn't say come pick me up he
was like let's meet here or something
and it was his house oh [ __ ]
pretty sure he didn't say
let's go to taco bell he gave her
directions
and they ended up at a time no way
wow
also so so at the end
real brilliant yeah once she hit her
breaking point she took the rest of the
tacos back because she paid for it oh
she took it she's like what the [ __ ]
was he like hey
she doesn't say that's funny as [ __ ] the
dad my feet
you think this is like that guy's like
first rodeo with that or just it sounds
like he's he's doing it so much that you
know what's crazy is if you swap the
genders and if i get into a car with a
chicken and she's like let's go talk
about get a and she proceeds to order
100 tacos i'm like this chick's pretty
[ __ ] big
girl go back to her spot it's her she's
like let's feed her show me her studio
okay that's true incredible because
there isn't a weird [ __ ] danger
element if i'm a chick i'd be like i'm
about to get murdered but if it was the
other way around like they tried
something [ __ ] up
yeah cause the student's talking about i
will beat this chick up and she's gonna
kill me yeah she try something i'ma
punch her in the face dude that's true
the danger element doesn't exist for us
yeah and i think the stereotypical guy's
a loser so this behavior matches the
loser behavior
i want to see what this guy looks like
though he has to be [ __ ] hot as [ __ ]
yeah of course he has to be looking like
zach
but if you're eating 100 taco bell tacos
i don't know about that guys maybe
that's just it was just taco tuesday
maybe on friday he's eating something
like he might be so broke that he's
saving those or maybe he's michael
phelps he's doing like
15 calories 15 000 calories a day and
obviously it's between him and his dad
and who knows how many other family
members are like waiting to eat some
tacos i love that he's either hot as
[ __ ] or michael phelps right now yeah
well it was a it was a hot girl right
i'm only assuming she was an influencer
or whatever i didn't find her hot okay
did you find her hot i'm not gonna
comment on that okay never mind
can you can we just show
we won't say anything i just want to see
we'll judge her no because when you say
it
i all of a sudden thought it was some
like hot instagram girl now it's a bunch
of ugly [ __ ] she averaged at least
or no i would say average i mean i i
wouldn't i wouldn't call her ugly no
no no
no because you could kind of see the
scale like of who they're going to go
for based off of what they look like too
oh dang joe's going there no no give him
give the one from the video
okay all right you wouldn't understand
any sex have her yeah you sex however
i've never heard that [ __ ] you know just
buy you 100 tacos all the time dude
dude your brand is [ __ ] anthony
we're exposing you dude yeah it's kind
of pixelated but you're going to get the
idea sarah silverman's sister sarah
silverman's sister yeah yeah she just
looks like a typical girl like a red
yeah
yeah she's got two eyes and a nose big
[ __ ] mug dude that's like she has a
big glass of milk she looks like she
went on a bad date she looks traumatized
yeah i want to show the prettier one
yeah when she's like not her face isn't
screened yeah i don't want to i don't
want the picture where she's like i just
bit through some [ __ ] or she's like
partially blinking talking yeah oh yeah
this is her yeah she's cute yeah she's
cute
so like i don't know like usually you
know girls that can date guys
they're gonna go for yeah they're gonna
get they're gonna get guys that are good
looking i mean it was on tinder or
something so she had to find him
attractive yeah right she swiped on them
yeah can we
there's no uh she doesn't is her tick
tock her explaining it that's it
oh okay
i don't know she's like capturing
footage of the dad walking in and dirty
that's face and [ __ ] i'll be [ __ ]
turn that's in that sweatshirt telling
the story yeah that's true how many
girls did this dude do it to where he's
that comfortable pulling this off he's
probably very comfortable he had to have
this he's got a routine right like a way
to speak about like you know meet at
this place was [ __ ] telling you that
she's gamified bro yeah [ __ ]
because and there's girls on the other
end doing the same [ __ ] too my favorite
i wonder if i honestly wonder if taco
bell had something to do with this
because my favorite picture of this
experience is one of the thumbnails in
one of the news articles has this and
i'm like dude talk about tacos not look
like that nah not even that's not taco
bell that's [ __ ] bj's tacos
who did this wait what are we eating for
lunch again because that looks good yo i
think i'm gonna get taco bell after
though
because i usually like del taco but for
some reason yeah you got it in your head
now taco bell's delicious i like that i
like del taco with the dell score shows
you like they'll taco more than taco
bell i do i do like to talk more that's
what i'm talking about bro the chicken
tacos i'm the only one here dale taco
chicken tacos are better than most
things
and they're but taco bell beef tacos you
can't beat that
[Music]